Now to our booze news.
Well done.
Late night on CNN.
If you're a regular viewer
of CNN tonight,
you know, we bring you the latest.
Jack Daniels news tonight exclusively.
And tonight is no different.
But this time
it involves the Supreme Court.
Lawyers for the whiskey maker
Jack Daniels are suing
the makers of a doggy chew toy called
Bad Spaniels, claiming the chew toy.
We also have sound effects
claiming the chew
toy violates their trademark.
For some reason,
the Supreme Court
justices found this funny.
To it.
What is the parody here?
The parody. Parody?
Because I
maybe I just have no sense of humor, but
what's the parody?
The parody is multi-fold.
But the testimony indicates
and it's not being disputed,
that the parody is to make fun of Marx
and take themselves seriously.
I mean, you say that, but, you know,
you make fun of a lot of Marx
doggy walker dose Perot's smell of arpa
canine cola mt.
and Ruel.
Are all of these companies
taking themselves too seriously?
Yes.
All right, so here are the products.
So I'm sure you reckon
you all recognize Jack Daniels.
I've never seen that.
I've been out with you.
And then the attitude toy
looks like this.
So do you think this is violating?
This is trademark?
Yes.
And I don't want to be the wet
blanket on this panel
because this is funny.
But trademark law is really important
and it protects IP.
And I think.
Absolutely they are trying to.
It's a parody.
Yes, a brand.
But in the process,
I think they're damaging the brand
and that is the argument that, listen, if
if if the parody doesn't damage the brand
a little bit, it's not a good parody.
That's the whole point of parody.
And that's why you have the exception
for parody. So I think
that's what they're considering.
The I don't I don't
I don't drink alcohol.
I don't have a dog.
So this really doesn't apply to me.
But I just think in general that,
you know, chill out.
If you unless you can prove
that you lost
in sales,
then, well, here,
maybe this will change your thinking.
I'll put this to you.
It says Jack
Daniels product is 40% alcohol by volume.
Bad Spaniels Toy is said to be 43% pooh.
No. Want to read now?
Do you want to rethink that reputation?
But I guess I stand by my.
You know what
I find so interesting about this?
Well, first of all,
one of the only good things
that came out of it was that we have now
audio livestream from the Supreme Court.
So we're able to listen
in on these people.
Now, the day
probably will never come
that we have video of them
because hopefully not
because that will just change
the Supreme Court acts
and they'll be acting
for the camera, etc.
But it's great to be able to hear them
and you're like,
Oh, these are the people
making important decisions.
What was also very fascinating
in this time of a63
conservative liberal split
in left, right, etc., was
you had a couple
interesting alliances
in terms of the discussions
you had Alito and Sotomayor,
who were very much
your take being like,
come on, come on, really?
Jack Daniels, seriously.
And then you had Gorsuch and Kagan
who are like, don't get involved in this.
Oh, well, more legacy,
but like this still lower court.
But you had this
these interesting conservative
liberal matchups
that, again,
you could hear in their tone,
not just the transcript.
And so it's hard
to predict how this will go,
but it seem like I don't know,
generally speaking,
it'll I'll be surprised
by if this ruling comes into effect.
I totally agree
that it was interesting to hear them
because we got to hear some Supreme Court
humor there.
They were really yucking it
up, Congressman.
So, first off, one owner of a dog
named Baxter tells me that they received
this chew
toy specifically and the dog hated it.
And I thought that
is an important data point.
Secondly, I would agree with S.E.
on the legal analysis.
It's a lot of work
to go through the trademark.
Look,
there's a reason
why we have this trademark law in place.
There is an impact on the brand.
And I think that Jack Daniels
will likely be successful.
So we'll see where it goes.
I mean, guys,
obviously, if we're going to talk
any more about this,
we really would have to do a deeper dove
research, research into the product
following the story.
I will be the first to tell everyone.
That's actually the second bottle
for the night for us that believe it.
All right.
Thank you all very much.
There may be drinks
during the commercial break.
I don't know what to say.